[Music]
we we got some good news for all you
Marvel Fanatics out there we got finally
got a real new trailer I don't think we
have any Marvel Fanatics out here
for the New Black Panther and guess what
the New Black Panther we nailed it gonna
be a woman
this is very touching you can tell cause
a piano it's doing the bling bling yeah
you know this is going to be a real
moment yeah
[Music]
can somebody okay I'm gonna ask a
question
and I'm sure you guys can do it if
somebody could do it maybe leaning me in
tape or one of you guys are really good
at this
can you take the footage from
Ace Ventura 2 when he's with the African
tribe
and re-cut it just with this music same
trailer
but just use footage from that thank you
[Music]
only the most broken people
great leaders
oh boy African rap
like this is another one of those
trailers where you're like I don't know
what's happening
my people and my family even though we
are in Africa and among our own people
we do not speak our language we speak
English because Marvel is filming a
movie here
they call him
you're a child
football
they call him
no Virgie this is childish
[Music]
which is what everybody in this trailer
should be playing instead of making this
movie this whole movie is
oh [ __ ] but seriously like why aren't
they talking their own language amongst
each other why are they speaking bad
English to each other because nobody
pays to see movies in Africa
because they don't have movies in Africa
no well Chinese ones they've gone in
Nigerian action films no actually I did
see I did see I see Ghana in 90 seconds
and it was really good
[Laughter]
Ghana in 90 seconds because that's how
long it took the Chinese to buy the
whole country
surprisingly
uh Nicholas Cage still in it
oh that's right I forgot Namor has
[ __ ] bird feet in the comics wait
what he really does in the comics but
the one thing the Neymar wasn't was
Mexican so for some reason Neymar's
Mexican and he's underwater and you're
gonna tell me I'm not gonna make a
[ __ ] joke that's on me I can't make a
[ __ ] joke okay whatever
for the surface world
this looks so bad oh yeah Superman
don't you love when there just happens
to be huge empty streets in major cities
where you could just have cars do this
oh yeah because they have to film the
scene
[Music]
no no
no one time
mark my words this movie's gonna do okay
but it's not gonna be like this huge
like a normal Marvel release movie and
they're gonna blame it on racism
because now it's
with your racism the fact of the matter
is the guy who plays Black Panther's
dead and instead of recasting with
another dude you request it with a chick
not to mention the guy that played Black
Panther is by all accounts was like just
a beloved dude that like it's just not
gonna fill his shoes sorry like I it's
literally a testament to the fact that
the people that aren't going to see this
movie aren't racist because they all
really liked Chadwick Boseman but he's
dead so I don't know what to tell you
but that's a great Point that's like I
don't know making an Iron Man movie
without an Iron Man oh wait there's been
this is the spin-off this is going to be
Iron hard this is iron chicken because
we watched I think I watched this
trailer before no this is
similar similar trailer
um and as somebody said and I [ __ ]
wait I told you guys yesterday I love
their credit I forget who it was but
Iron woman should be a direction not a
movie
um
also where even let's say that she's
like oh I'm so inj like ingenuous like I
can I can make all this [ __ ] stuff by
hand where does she get all those
[ __ ] military grade Parts like those
O-rings alone would be [ __ ] you're
right military issue she stole them she
stole the point
no that's not a joke
in the comic book she really did steal
them that's not a joke so she's a thief
yes yeah no she stole it
I stole it
you eat dealing
show them
also this movie's not gonna do good for
another reason which is that like
pretty much Thanos was the peak right
yeah no after Thanos there's no
existential threat that anyone's gonna
give a [ __ ] about maybe Galactic we
already beat the guy that snapped his
fingers and made half the people not
exist like would he how do you top that
guy
you bring a merman
it is a merman isn't it he's a merman
yes with wing feet it's a female black
panther by the way they're doing this
with all this is this this is a Disney
Mo that they do
they do the entire trailer and then at
the end of it they reveal something you
weren't expecting like it's going to be
a woman or the little mermaid's black
they do it on purpose because they want
they want the Rage of course they want
the shock that Disney acts like they
don't want the rage but they love it it
only promotes the movie they love this
[ __ ] yeah Disney books trailers the way
Tony Khan books wrestling yes exactly
big reveal at the end whoa wait a minute
Black Panther's black I believe it gets
even better
they know that they're trying to Market
this as a Black Panther movie but it's
not so look look at the title wakanda
forever is the big part of the title
black panther
wakanda forever exactly
National Lampoon's presents wakanda
forever
super excited for this National
Lampoon's African vacation
we're staying at a hotel in Rwanda